i only have one more question and i'm
gonna shoot my shot here i would love to
take nine to 12 minutes of your time to
talk to you about nft is very smart what
you just did right there on comic books
i'm in for nine minutes in january um so
first gary i want to say thank you so
much for your time today i know you're a
very busy man i'm super pumped to get to
talk to you about comic books and nfts
and kind of where you see those two
things colliding real quick before we
get into that i just want to say thank
you again because you know i've been
doing this for a year as of saturday
full-time owning a business making
content and to think that in a year i
get to talk to a real-life superhero
such as yourself um absolutely
mind-blowing for me so thank you so much
they're very nice you know we're kind of
seeing a rise in indie comic books
creator-owned properties things like
that they're having a bit of a
renaissance and i just want to know
where you see that kind of colliding
with nfts and smart technology and smart
contract technology i believe that nfts
are the biggest medium to new character
creation since 1980s after school
television
ironically given the way you asked that
question i believe one of the greatest
platforms for character creation of all
time is comic books yeah definitely
right like i don't know what to tell
people but like
batman was a comic book yeah superman
was a comic you know and so it's fun
because i believe the next batman the
next superman and then taking it to
other formats the next transformers you
know those were cartoons made to sell
toys yeah and then we had
card games magic the gathering pokemon
that became a platform right
i believe nmts will create the most
significant new ip that we've seen in a
very long time that board ape cool cats
world of women
be friends
who knows which ones but 15 to 25 of
these properties 50 will come out of
this era
and become popular culture in 20 30
years how do i see it i see it as nfts
is the greatest thing that ever happened
to independent comic creators here's why
the likelihood of being an independent
comic right now
printing a book and creating spider-man
is impossible yeah we haven't seen it
since spawn right yeah
right and i think we can agree that
spawn's unbelievable but let there be no
confusion spawn is not batman superman
yeah so we haven't seen it because the
format's not big enough
to do it in the 40s 50s 60s 70s you had
almost every kid reading a comic book
yeah yeah
thus thus giving spider-man he-man
shazam
you know fantastic four x-men a chance
today that happens in video games
fortnite
can become spider-man if they go if
super mario for example is much bigger
than spawn yeah so the
medium joel matters the medium of just a
comic book isn't big enough anymore to
create that big of a character i believe
that nfts will be a big enough medium
and a lucrative enough medium and i
think if you're an independent comic
book person i think you launch an nft
first
and then make the book would you say for
like a collector getting into it should
they focus more you kind of mention the
blockchain technology should they focus
on learning about the technology and
like how that could be applied to the
assets or should they you know kind of
follow their gut you know i know comic
books i don't know technology as well so
i'm following i know this comic book
character is popular which would you say
i think they matter because i think i
think both matter
just because you understand ethereum or
cardona or immutable or magic like if
you don't understand what people are
going to want you're dead yeah at the
same token you know for me with vb like
you know and other digital
infrastructures
getting that
business development deal with the right
blockchains [ __ ] matters yeah
definitely who is your favorite comic
book character could be a superhero not
superhero team it's batman
uh batman i'll tell you why i learned
how to speak english by watching the old
60s batman yeah
price is right mm-hmm
and batman were the shows i watched
and a little bit of a credible hulk yeah
you know with bill bixby yeah but batman
is my
is my number one that's awesome that's
awesome
and the 89 batman film came out
like you know in the 80s there was the
superman movies in the early 80s yeah
and they were big but 89 batman
really is what i would say the precursor
to what we're living today definitely it
hits so big culturally that's awesome
yeah that better put everybody on notice
that superhero movies were a real thing
[Music]